[Music]
Katie why did you bring me my Christmas
present tonight welcome to the inaugural
2020 issue of black man beyond my name
is Mark Barnard and I am joined by just
awesomeness like [ __ ] I feel whatever
like Katee Sackhoff patricia
every year
[Applause]
so so Trisha was supposed to be on the
for if some of you guys remember and I
flaked at the last moment you didn't
flake you definitely definitely ill yes
and and you were like I can't make it
and I said oh alright then I guess we'll
just cancel the show and she said but no
but wait yeah Katie's gonna come I said
oh [ __ ] alright thank you in is she
sober now don't worry about it the bar
but Katie came and she killed it and
then she's like but I want to come and
do it now and so now we're all doing
this show how are you guys
how would you new use how was your
holidays how was your Christmases
Hanukkah Kwanzaa we celebrated
everything all along I was in bed at
10:15 on New Year's and I've never in
bed at 10:15 like a boiler on a regular
day no you say you fall asleep on the
couch a lot yeah and yeah yeah so I was
a I was very lame on New Year's Eve but
you got to do that every once in a while
right yeah we uh we were my boyfriend
and I were you went out to dinner early
we couldn't get a reservation so we were
like let's just go at five
it really done with dinner like 7:45 and
I came home and he did the senior
special good it was amazing and it was
really great and then we were laying in
bed watching Rick and Morty when the
only reason we knew it was New Year's
was we heard a bomb go off and thanks
but Chihuahua was like and then he
leaned over and goes Happy New Year baby
and that was it and then we went back to
Rick good morning sounds amazing how was
yours I was surrounded by a flock of
like 80 year old Irish people but I like
fun Irish just like New Jersey Irish
somebody said drunk people
yeah just like banging pots because
apparently that's the thing that they do
yeah I should get weird we're gonna stop
at banging just banging a bunch of
eight-year-olds evident orgy a lot of
creaking somewhere later there was
ironically a pot there wasn't a denture
that went loose so it was kind of awful
but hey New Year's but I did the thing I
did the date in New Year's Day I went to
go see I was in New York what do we see
the Rockettes the radio see records have
you ever done this no but that is just I
mean they so iconic Lee Christmas it's
bonkers it is the weirdest [ __ ] form
of entertainment I've ever seen which is
hey you know what's cool legs I know
right well you know what's even cooler
like 40 pairs of them moving at once
doing like with no story around it just
we're gonna march out here put our arms
around each other and just kick for a
while and they just didn't stop their
choreography you know kicking the [ __ ]
out of so what's wrong with you military
I don't know she's so [ __ ] angry and
like it's it's not even dance really cuz
this it's just it's like watching an
airshow it's like have military
procession it totally is
but then they rap like this weird
[ __ ] Christmas story around it where
first it's hey let's go for a tour of
New York on this bus
driven by Rockettes and then your unlike
this bus that's just kind of like hey
look at the Statue of Liberty lose and
then you get on like Santa's poor nose
that started like that I mean this would
have been like way more interesting if
anything else happened and then they're
like they give you 3d glasses and I'm
like why don't we 3d glasses there's
girls on the stage it's all 3d but then
like no we're taking you in like a VR
tour of New York so then you're like
Santa's sleigh and you put on these
glasses and this is [ __ ] like really
badly animated version of like a tour of
New York and then camels are on stage
because the three wise men are like
walking across the stage and you know
who plays the wise men Rockettes like
showing in theatres no man are their
legs showing when they're playing no
because of God so we're like no this is
a classy part and then Santa comes out
[ __ ] yeah and then like Santa comes out
and he talks to these two like immigrant
kids they're like I gotta buy a present
for my sister let's go to North Pole and
there's 40 Santa's at the North Pole
they're all Rockettes but like every 18
minutes there's a reason for like the
Rockettes they'll come out and kick a
lot and I'm like but when did this ever
be entertainment like 1932 where as what
guys
it's been a long we lost a lot of money
in the stock market crash you know what
I could really do right now [ __ ] legs
right yeah legs make everything better
put like what are they gonna do kick a
lot kids perform a lot for the troops
okay let's make like us yeah but like
really like enduring like World War two
and stuff I would guess that there were
like Rockets they put on a plane dropped
about
they won't shoot the legs so that was my
New Year's it was like this is weird and
like kind of crazy objectification but
for kids yeah I love to have been at
that tea that round table of like ladies
how do we stay current I know
camels 3ds big and they have live
[ __ ] camels who walk out on the stage
live camels yeah yeah PETA is gonna have
a field day that's what the elixir for
it you know and I saw some movies did
you guys watch I mean like Oscar movies
does the Oscar nominations I think -
yeah three what which one 19:17 okay
Joker and once upon a time in Hollywood
oh yeah I've seen some - that that's
what we're talking about them yeah [ __ ]
I haven't seen nineteen seventeen
nineteen nineteen seventy okay good it's
really good it's really good no I've
heard it's amazing I just like loved it
I just I need to go you need to you need
to see the movies yes I think I've seen
the nineteen seventeen yet I will spoil
one thing we win the war but no I'll
spoil another thing is that the conceit
of the movie is that it's all one shot
like it's it's sort of I know it's great
I mean it's not really one shot but
that's the cake it's it's built as if
it's a Warner so you're literally just
following these two guys is they're on
this mission till like we got to bring
these orders to the front lines to stop
a giant attack and I spent the first
like ten minutes like looking for the
cut yeah and then you get tired of
looking friends they walk through the
door there's a [ __ ] cut right there
oh there's some [ __ ] they cut
hiding it dark there so that's a cut so
you [ __ ] cut but then after a while
just like you get hypnotized by it he
said I'm in the story I'm in the movie
and and the filmmaking is just
ridiculous it's brilliant
you know coincidentally on the way here
I got in my car and on the radio was the
co-writer Christy o talking to whatever
station it was on about writing that and
she was saying sort of like with tension
one of the things that they had she was
paying attention to they were paying her
and Sam were paying attention to was in
these one-shot type movies which are she
didn't have any really reference to go
off of was sort of like when there's too
much tension or something something
breaks the ice or something miss you
laughs to kind of break the tension give
the audience a time time to breathe and
she said when they were writing that
they were concerned about that but due
to the one-shot ness of it that if the
audience is like too much kind of going
along with it they had to break up a
little bit of with a story like a little
bit less action a little bit less you
know are they gonna get shot are they
gonna get shot but also with the
dialogue not just with the action yeah
yeah and it's it's gorgeous there's
there's a sequence in there that take it
you know it's it's a day pretty much in
this guy's life is he's going for one
place or another and so at night there's
a sequence in this bombed out village
and they're like flares going overhead
and the shadows just like marching
across the frame it's just it's the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen where
people also die in it they had to do it
with wires right and take out the wires
yeah the flares they had were on wires
they weren't just shooting flares and so
you mean for the camera and for the
camera yeah there was there's a but
there's a great making of thing that's
on YouTube now so you see how they do it
and so a lot of its handheld and then
they're putting the camera on a crane
and then the crane is taking it and then
they're taking it off the crane and
putting it on a rig on a motorcycle and
it dude driving it it's crazy [ __ ]
nuts
I think they should win just for the
feet event alone yeah most movie 1917
yeah that's awesome
that's great I haven't seen it
I will do I saw mr. Rogers movie
beautiful day a lot of people were
slightly disappointed because not be
with the movie but because it was
something different than they thought it
was gonna be they thought they were
gonna get like a mr. Rogers biopic and
what you get is this story about a
journalist who was assigned and he's
like a kind of war correspondent like a
political journalist who was assigned a
profile of mr. Rogers and in doing so it
reveals the many and varied ways this
guy's broken like his religion his
father's lazy with his wife with his kid
like he's just he's a he's an unsettled
soul and how interacting with Fred
Rogers kind of puts him back on the path
but there's a part of that movie that
it's in a trailer so I'm not spoiling
anything where mr. Rogers is on the
subway and he's sitting there talking
this guy and the kids down the subway
like hey mr. Rogers and you're like they
got a mug mr. Rogers but then they start
singing the theme song and like it is
the most pure beautiful thing like I've
ever seen again I'm just like it's the
most beautiful scene I've ever seen this
year oh yeah I was a mess like crying
like a baby it's it's um watching Tom
Hanks at the Golden Globes inspired me
to like go back and watch some of his
movies that I absolutely like adored
over the years and then we just watched
Philadelphia and like I've seen the
movie many many times so you know what's
coming and then I get to the end and
it's like the last you know that scene
with with Tom Hanks and and Antonio
Banderas it's like the very end when he
looks at him and says I'm ready now or
I'm ready to go and you think oh does he
want to go home
[Music]
because it's such a sweet way that he
said he says it in such a like I'm ready
to go and you're like oh cool
and then I blubber for like but he was
looking a really nice way like he's only
me with taking it back to mr. Rogers um
do you think I've I've never seen
anything I didn't grow up watching you
know anything with mr. Rogers does not
have mr. Rogers in Canada I didn't have
a TV that's right though you grew up in
this donut group the Sun I just when I
have the same kind of nostalgia to like
that scene hurt for instance or the the
movie would it impact me the same I mean
the question the movie does a decent job
of explaining why he was as special as
he was it is not quite as good as the
documentary that came out last year
called won't you be my neighbor which is
like literally just archival footage and
like he's passed away so you can't talk
to him anymore but it does a better job
of telling the Mister Rogers story and
why he was so special and so amazing but
it's the the thing that always gets me
is my weakness my soft spot is for a
life's work recognized and that's that
moment where like he just did this thing
every day for like 40 years because he
loved it and to watch the the response
of the world to him and just walking
through it
I was just a [ __ ] mess I get my mom
is next I took the screener back home
and I'm sitting on the couch at my mom's
here my wife's there my son is there and
I'm just a wreck like what's the matter
[Music]
no does that come from a family of
robots I grew up on mr. Rogers I loved
every aspect of the show that in Captain
Kangaroo
that guy's a deviant
yeah deviant I mean I don't know I don't
know weren't allowed to watch be way my
can we turned on an episode of pee-wee's
Playhouse one time and it would just
happen to be the episode where he had
this large pair of Underpants on his
head and my family was very white group
very Christian and my mom just came in
and went nope we were never allowed
kazumi my mother was like he's a
pedophile I'm here like no he's not
what's a pedophile your mom was in on
the joke [ __ ] you're right and the last
one I saw on the plane was book smart
book smarts amazing no don't even know
what it's about Olivia Wilde
Olivia Wilde directed it and it's about
these two these two girls in high school
they're about to graduate and they spent
their entire high school career focused
like hyper focus on their studies to the
detriment of everything else in their
lives and so they decided on this last
day of high school that they were just
going to [ __ ] go for it
they'd spent four years being nerds and
now they were gonna be awesome
and following their like crazy like one
last night kind of riot Tripp is lovely
but it's so precisely observed about the
lives of these two girls and how they
were linked with each other and relate
with the world and relate with their
peers and the love they have for each
other and how that love is kind of
colored and a little lopsided to a
certain degree and it's it's so clear
eyed about gender and sex and an
orientation and it and there's a moment
in the it towards the end of that movie
that is the most second most beautiful
thing I've seen it's just she dives into
a pool and it means everything at that
moment when she just like I'm going for
it
which was like a teenage girl right now
because I would feel everything that was
the worst part about being a teenage
girl by the way feeling everything all
the time I never stopped mmm yeah being
a teenage boy was also awful because you
felt nothing why is this so stupid I
thought that that did you think that
that movie was just a too long I feel
like most comedies are too long yeah
like it's a little Apatow that way yeah
dude you could have pulled 40 minutes
out of this is it's like three false
ending yeah one of these big one anyone
will do
I was upset however when I saw the Oscar
nominations that that there was no love
for book-smart at all mmm it was it was
it was a relatively disappointing Oscar
season I didn't even see who was
nominated I will give you a hint mm-hmm
everybody's white must be poor men
apparent almost everybody like if there
is no women who directed any movies I
know progress yeah marches on yeah the
only the only person of color in the
acting categories at all was Cynthia
areevo for Harry Harry which I mean
she's great the movies interesting but
it's very telling that the only black
actress who could be nominated was
nominated for playing a slave lots of
other actresses have done here I mean
alfre woodard still don't have an Oscar
in she's just playing a lady who does
some [ __ ] and it does it also dancing
got nominated twice yeah because she's
twice his wife fame no leave you can
just use twice as much she's twice his
wife yes supporting and Lee for the same
movie share for the same movie nothing
for Jo Jo Jo rabbit and lead for Mary
yeah so hey listen I a lot of the movies
that you came out we're really good and
really interesting but I didn't like
once upon a time in Hollywood I didn't
like it either
III I thought it was i watch it
completely confounded like what is I
mean it's shot already was it what's the
point
boom quite a nice it's Quentin Quentin
is the most indulgent filmmaker working
and sometimes that indulgence he pays
off
like I really liked inglourious basterds
great I really didn't care for hateful
eight and like discrete scenes in this
movie are interesting everybody's doing
really good work but it's just for me it
never added up to a story that felt like
it had any energy or propulsion anyway
yeah I thought Margot Robbie was
completely wasted in that movie and then
celebrated for it it was strange she's
nominated for that yeah good oh no for
bombshell sorry no for bombs like
Germany are crawling in my rocket I know
nothing I guess garbage well yeah I was
uh I was a little underwhelmed but yeah
it's one of those every years different
there are some years where it feels as
if we are making some progress and some
sense of parody that oh yeah there are
actually people beyond the standard who
are making stuff and like the fact that
little women didn't get much of anything
Hustler's didn't get anything yeah guys
did you see [ __ ] J Lo's ass she's 50
years old I'm gonna work you put into
that [ __ ] for the upper stomach inspire
everyone any Murphy was amazing in
dolomite rain like Eddie Murphy it was
just one of those like Haran I guess
it's gonna be like it used to be yeah I
mean I'd listen it's it's such a strange
thing to comment on when you know I grew
up looking like so many people that are
in these categories you know and so I
feel like I am not necessarily entitled
to an opinion you know however I do you
think that the under-representation of
women in film as far as the directing
category is is appalling I think that
we've got so many amazing female writers
and and directors that are that are
underappreciated and at working twice as
hard to get the opportunities and I
think that's really disappointing I read
something that the the thought is that a
lot of the Academy that are making the
decisions aren't necessarily not voting
for it's they're not watching the movies
so it's not even on their radar in terms
of being able to vote for them or choose
I heard lupito I haven't seen the movie
but she did amazing in some movie that
she did choosing us and but I'm
ambivalent about the movie the
performance is really strong but there's
a vast swath you're right of the voters
the the viewership the voter body of the
Oscars who just were never gonna watch
that movie you know they're never gonna
watch the farewell to know that aquafina
is as good as she is there was little
witness done mean her performance was
just like yeah amazing absolutely
amazing and so it's I think you're right
it's the it's the diversifying the the
body of the Academy will help to
diversify the kinds of movies at that
body watches that then it gets to vote
on and so they're trying they're doing
their best how big is the Academy um I
think it's something like thirteen
fourteen hundred nine hundred nine
hundred total but the cut the class last
year was the biggest had ever had which
was like five hundred and thirty five
people
what is the diversity like inside of the
Academy it is overwhelmingly male it's
overwhelmingly old and it's
overwhelmingly white it's all like over
fifty is the average age something like
seventy percent male and 90% do you like
they never get kicked out is it like bad
teachers they've got ten years
I remember like weekly we wrote a story
about Ron Howard's Apollo 13 Oscar
campaign hmm and because he comes from a
long like Hollywood family one of his
first stops was always the retirement
home because there's a bunch of old
actors and writers and directors who
never drop out of the Academy who are
all like haven't worked in 20 some odd
years and like hey I made a movie just
for you guys
bunch of astronauts DNA well that's not
[ __ ]
is there legitimacy to this story like
it's actually it's actually a thing like
and it has become a whistle-stop on the
Oscar campaign tour of you gotta go the
old folks home we gotta talk to them to
retirees we got it because there are the
largest voting bloc nothing against old
people know I love old people especially
when they have lots of sex at New Year's
Day it is a little strange though that
the Academy is not an accurate
representation of the viewing body of
the entire country it feels like it
should be huh yeah it's not them but
they don't have a host this year again
right no host they're just host less
post less I thought Rick Asian race was
awesome we were dying laughing but you
were the thing Lord I snorted so hard
and rough with my boyfriend's ear then
he was like oh my god babe oh we're
looking so hard we saw it with a bunch
of Battlestar people it was Michael
trucco and his wife and James callous
and us and Sharn and a bunch of us yeah
and the I wasn't there I mean I I'm not
in the family so that's fine but she's
saying
sorry but we were all laughing so hard
that I actually at one point looked over
and James's kids we're all looking at
the adults like we were all laughing
like just and the kids didn't think it
was as funny as we did I can love every
second of it being a Yoda Joe Pesci
sorry I I got to watch it after the fact
because I was invited to a cool party
but I I appreciate the the Ricky Gervais
of it all but I'm always a little
suspect of it because he is as much a
part of that community as anybody else
and for that but the weird slight like
holier than thou I'm going to tell you
what's wrong with you as if it's not
also what's wrong with him it's always a
little like dude like he owned that too
though you wouldn't know it though like
watching that monologue it never it
always feels as if he's chastising an
industry for the things they do wrong of
which he is funny apart who does the
same things wrong it's funny he has
acknowledged that in his tweets he's
like look I'm the biggest left-liberal
there is but a joke is a joke but you're
right he did skewer everybody which he's
a part of you're right um but uh good
for that guy getting paid to think that
every four or five years like I'm gonna
be bad you guys just you weigh well
drink up and when I tell these [ __ ]
stars that they're morons no he's like
like the after party if he goes or he's
just like I'm gonna go back to my hotel
room I don't think I'm gonna be really
welcome there tonight
straight through the TSA line well I
think that with our talk about the
Oscars we have segue it officially into
the news you guys we're talking about
some news I cancelled my cable so did
you yeah so I don't know not that that's
news
I just man I don't watch it anymore so
whatever news I get I'm getting from
Twitter
excellent it's probably more reliable I
feel current the Television Critics
Association winter session is going on
in Pasadena and if you don't know what
that is that is when the networks sort
of parade their upcoming wares and
decide to make a ton of announcements
and they bring out the cast of the new
shows and so we're in that we're
catching that wave of announcements and
the one that I found most interesting is
that CBS is making a Clarice Starling
show Clary Slattery's
which takes place after Silence of the
Lambs but before the other movies and
it's like her sort of first year as a
full-fledged FBI agent I know right
[ __ ]
tell me you're not like it's it's for
real though Hannibal Lecter's not
expected to be and said TV show I think
they they're they'll probably save that
I think for like sweeps who guess who's
coming to dinner my chihuahua makes that
exact same face when he licks my pugs
vagina what sorry I mean whoa I didn't
hear the beginning of that was an adult
here wah wah okay like gets up in my
other it's how they say hello
and every time he doesn't he goes away
like this is so gross I don't know why I
just thought of this but I saw a picture
of Sarah Silverman today that she posted
where she's she's got her legs but she's
sitting there like sitting up got her
legs spread and she's got holding her
iPhone in front of her crotch and you
look and you're like oh that's a and
then you zoom in of course we all and
how many who have you done and I take
rice um anyway it's it's a picture of a
man's mouth sideways big list and all
you see at first glance all you see is
two vagina
and then and then you zoom in and
there's like there's like whiskers and a
mustache around it and a beard like I
mean it's kind of funny it's pretty
brilliant anyway sorry dude no I feel
like I've lost control of this show in
the best way
what did you think happened nothing to
do with Clarice but I was still your
crazy freaky dog sex house that's like
my chihuahua it's going to town on my
pug well not so much we put her in a
kennel now when he leaves because he
can't be bested she tore her ACL and we
think it's because she was trying to get
away from him when we were gone or just
bending in the wrong way while they were
still there I put that leg what I like
it Oh so Clarice Starling yeah is it
Starling or sterling Starling did you
have it spelled both ways on your sheets
do I I will believe that a sheet yeah I
didn't give it to you oh my god you gave
her a [ __ ] cheat sheet he did say I
could give it to you but he said you
didn't like get it last time you didn't
time you're like [ __ ] it let's fly blind
you offered me this last time
see it's it's sterling and then Starling
I'm going to play [ __ ] deadline from
which I copy pasted this we're not
having a really good research in fact
checkers that's amazing that you offered
that to me and I said no I mean do you
want to look at this one no no that's
exactly what you said last another you
can slip it to her if she watch it and
wonder from me you guys are here to do
the work I'm here to you know be
inappropriate we're off to a bang-up
story take a little sandwich yeah so
yeah they've already got a writers room
up and running I think they don't have a
cast yet for who's going to play Clarice
Starling do you guys have an affinity
for the character your songs of the
Lambs fan it was the first movie that I
watched when I was a
kid teenager child whatever I whenever
it came out that gave me such nightmares
I couldn't sleep for I just couldn't
yeah when did it come out that seems I
was older then I was just thinking how
inappropriate my father let me watch
that when I was eleven okay the lotion
in the basket yeah yeah yeah no it's not
the right way I must have there must
have been something before that that was
scary
I'm thinking of because 91 I was like
sixteen or something
fifteen I don't know unless you saw it
in the theater like it's completely
realistic that you saw it like around
that time or if you did see it in the
theater you're still at home at that
point anyway it scared the bejesus out
of me and I couldn't sleep for her so
then will you be tuning in for Clarice
eventually yeah you know I probably I'll
check it out I have such a I so badly
wanted to get uh I can't even remember
the name ever right now Jesus Christ
a new show know the serial killer one
that I wanted to do get going oh not my
inventors no Yuri Hertz
yeah Hertz acting but Chelsea Kane and I
tried for like two years to get it going
and it was always not the right time it
was like we don't want a female serial
killer we don't want this we don't then
the following goes on and whatever and
now I've aged out of the room it's gonna
go to somebody else but so I'm always
like a little bit just a little bit ego
hurt and pissy when it comes to things
but I always end up watching them
because I love them I'm drawn to to that
reading it though not watching it I get
too scared I love to read it I love to
read it but I get to she still hasn't
watched Game of Thrones cuz she read the
books I'm waiting for the last two
dammit
I I mean I even though I don't know what
is in any of the books because I won't
read them because I forgot how to read
me - that's why I didn't want I see I
have a feeling that whatever you get in
the last two books you'll like more than
what people got in the last two seasons
I'm just saying a little heartsick over
it gabber in the heart
I like it I think that you know CBS has
got this this sort of thing going
they've got evil right now which is
doing really well and people seem to
love it so I mean I haven't seen it
because I cancelled my cable but I hear
it's good so I don't know I like that
sort of that thing that networks are
doing where it's procedural but it's
serialized as well so you can sort of
follow along if you miss an episode it's
alright you just sort of yeah I'm hoping
that it's it somehow finds a way to be
different than most other procedurals
because darling it's such a good
character and so much of that stories
about it's it's less about Hannibal
Lecter and it's more about her
confronting her own demons in her own
past and and finding ways to to reclaim
her own agency in a world that seems not
built for her great character for
someone to dive into for sure though so
so don't like multi-dimensional and
flawed and messed up and just hope it's
not like a regular little cut drama
starring Clarice Starling the plucky
young graduate from Ed's Quantico but
for CBS you're thinking that's probably
the good chance it's going that way it
could be that way
I hope not but it could be were you guys
uh okay okay good
Doctor Strange fans of the make of the
original love the movie that came out is
Doctor Strange with been a number but
I've never seen it you never seen it
I'll be saying that a lot tonight I'm
sorry
I liked it I really liked it I think
that he's so interesting to watch and I
thought that it was sort of this like a
hero that was sort of like relatable if
that makes any Stoli does and I think he
follows in the mold of a lot of Marvel
heroes which is like here's the the
plucky cocksure egocentric dude who is
humbled by something he decides to take
what he's learned and fight crime with
it but I was I was taken by just how the
movie looked like it looked unlike any
other Marvel movie I'd seen before
because there's always like dimensional
folding and crazy alternate like
parallel realms it was really textured
yeah they get really just viewing it it
just seems like it wasn't as bright and
shiny as most Marvel movies yeah for
sure and I was really excited they're
making a sequel because this is the
world we live in it was gonna Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness but
the director of the first one is no
longer going to be directing the second
one Scott Derrickson has parted ways
with Marvel due to quote-unquote
creative differences
mm-hmm which can mean a number of
different things in Hollywood my gut is
that it means that they wanted him to
hit a release date but he didn't think
he could make a good movie and hit and
because Marvel is you know to both their
credit in the detriment they're a
machine yeah I have a plan and every
movie needs to come out when it comes
out because there's another movie coming
out for months it's got to be part of
that and it's it's the fabric of the way
they tell stories and Kevin Feige is the
creative sort of Godhead who sits at the
top of that particular pyramid and so
it's very much my way or the highway and
it seems as if this came to a head where
Scott wanted either more time or the
script wasn't where he was happy with or
we want to make it look new and
different and awesome in ways if you
haven't cracked yet and Marvel said well
we got to have a movie out man right you
you have here mom it's May 7th 2021 so
that they have to get cracking on you
have to get cracking I mean it was
supposed to start shooting this coming
May and Wow the amount of time that it
takes to build one of there's no way
it's super [ __ ] hard it would be hard
even if the same guy was doing it mm-hmm
but if you've got to start from scratch
with a new director and a potential new
writer it's it's it's
not the most ideal way to make movies
I'll do it okay
we saw the Kevin Feige who's dr.
Strange's in the movie is it Benny plays
him benedict cumberbatch yes yeah no no
but plays his his buddy Wong Benedict
Wong
yes yeah I met him in Portugal this year
he was super cool he was very funny and
sweet he was just at a convention I was
at two he was so nice he's a good guy
yeah I had nothing at the convention we
did in London when we decided to do a
battle soar podcast he was just he was
willing to guess and hanging out the
greenroom and he just sat next to me one
day he's like hi I'm Benny how are you
said oh [ __ ] Wow how are you man what do
you do I do a dumb podcast like oh I'm
an activist guy no I've seen you in the
movies like every third movie yeah Benny
it was not quite as much fun as meeting
John rhys-davies John is fantastic I
have gotten pretty drunk I the first
errors of this convention we were in one
booth II was signing in the booth next
to me and like the most lovely man and
like clearly he was early 70s I think
like his knees were not quite what it
should be his back wasn't great he was
wearing a three-piece suit so behind
there and every time somebody came up
for his autograph he would stand up and
like reach over and shake their hand
dude like I see the the the effort
you're putting I see the exertion on
your face it's like well they came for
an autograph so I'm giving them the
thing and he would always pass me by and
he I don't think he ever knew my name
but he would pass my clap me on the
shoulders you handsome devil how are you
today
you're young buck you doing all right so
great I just and I'm like by that by the
end of it I was like listen man this is
weird I know I never do this but can I
take a picture with you because like I
know there's actually a lot of that that
goes back on you know at the conventions
yeah when when the curtains are closed
there's I have two cool ones actually
I'm gonna I'm gonna plug it here on my
website I just posted them because um
I'm doting on all the money to the wild
wildlife
we're doing the cameos as well but um
wires wires is a is an Australian it's a
New South Wales animal rescue and and
I'm gonna donate the said you don't know
anyway I'll just continue from my
shopsite I'm gonna donate to HBS or HS
us global who were also down there but
the reason I brought it up was I was
going I was trying to scrounge and find
everything I could to add more items to
my shop right and I found these three
that just happened to be backstage at
the convention and two or of me and
Clive Stanton and that guy one of them
is I am lifted literally like a like a
ballet or whatever like he's got he goes
just come and jump and I'm dancing I'm
like the you know belly dancing thing
you had the time of your life no I'm 6
feet tall and he lifted me and the first
time I was like I aborted it I was like
no I can't do it he said just trust me
and the picture is the fur full perfect
I'm ramrod straight and he's got me
lifted up in the air like this and my
face is going
right good okay let me down let me down
and he's literally got me just like that
dude can lift a girl up do you remember
when we were in Germany yeah that's the
Battlestar Galactica convention and you
were doing that with Michael trucco
Gabbar oh you know it's written 'cat I
wasn't you I was right guy sorry I think
I was telling the story you know the
story even right like I'm 100 pounds
lift me up and yeah and Michael trucco
was yeah we have some pictures of that
yeah on my phone probably of James
calots going there was some alcohol
involved there though anyway sorry I
totally know it hurts when I Jones came
up announced this is the point like I
listen we could just read these [ __ ]
news but it gives a [ __ ] I want to hear
about like a holy state rich in the air
and that's in convention I saw it was
the most adorable thing is Benedict
Cumberbatch angling to meet John Cleese
and he was so bashful and timid about it
you say as a [ __ ] Python over there I
know he's like can I go and he was like
like hopscotch like chicken a can I hop
in this double dutch not gonna go now I
finally did it it was like he just like
shrank like this mr. Gleeson such a big
fan everybody's a fan of somebody
including dr. strange and John Cleese is
like who are you he was cooler than that
I'm the dick
he was golden were uh were either of you
fans I think I know at least very one
answer to this question I'm not sure
about the other one fans of the
television show Firefly I've never seen
it I dated Nathan while he was filming
the pilot I did I told adult Katie that
this week I was not going to have any
news about her ex boyfriends
last week or was every question was like
so how do you feel about the new Star
Trek movie Katie this hey they're making
a Lord of the Rings show [ __ ]
again have you been to New Zealand so
now we're gonna ask Trish about her
there's always parental talk about a
Firefly reboot you know because he's so
much fun so much fun and that there's so
much love for that show even still 12
years since its cancellation or whatever
and part of the TCAs as we talked about
Fox executives are like yeah we'd do it
you know if there's a good idea for it
like yeah we're down we're all about
like exploiting IP that we already own
and making a TV show that we know it's a
built-in audience and and Tim Minear who
was the showrunner I said like I would
love to do what I can I'm making two
shows but but Josh might have a thought
or two okay
and then then suddenly everybody starts
tweeting stuff and like Nathan's
tweeting about it and alan tudyk is
tweeting about it yeah joe is tweeting
about that's how I knew about it yeah
like it I am I don't often like when
they just look let's go back to the well
for the sake of going back to the well I
was not a fan of the x-files reboot that
they just did because it's just that it
didn't have the it both was the same
show that I watched before but now like
the Emperor had no clothes and I see how
limiting that show was it was very much
product of its time and they never quite
updated it to be a modern day thing so
sometimes I'd leave well enough alone in
my memory it exists better than I feel
like it's going to be in a reboot but I
still just a continuation but would it
have to be a limited series to get
everybody back I mean Nathan is kind of
busy on the rookie and Alan's on a news
show and like it's hard to get everybody
back would you want it where it's why
thank you where it's like focused on
maybe marinas character or somebody else
or else it's as many people they can get
back and then somebody else playing
Captain Mal
I think it doesn't work unless you have
that cast back in some version you can't
have like a spark or like a group of
them you have to have everybody or
nobody write it like it
I mean Arrested Development did a
somewhat effective job of leg listen we
can't get everybody at the same time so
let's construct this sort of sequel so
that we can have this cluster together
and then we'll hand off to this cluster
together and then my hand up to this
cluster but I think probably a limited
series is the smartest way to do it like
six episodes just tell one big story and
get those dead cast back and and it's
it's a [ __ ] magical show and I would
just love to see more of it I'm all
about more if there is a show if you
could reboot or continue any show what
would you do I should maybe say not one
that you're in to remove the profit
motive
I would absolutely 100% love to do
longmeyer movies the series will never
happen again but movies like that we
serve fair so reason it wouldn't make
sense to me no exactly yeah but I think
that that was the continuation of sort
of like we thought they were gonna do it
like Jesse Stone movies sort of you know
along Myra movie every two years sort of
something like that and Warner Brothers
just was not into it
we sat down with them and he just was
like you know that's a great idea and
never heard back
I've heard that a couple times that
Warner Brothers can be somewhat
unwilling to make money yeah well
because they they own they own it but I
think Netflix has the rights to it for a
certain amount of time and I think if
they were to do a movie they would have
to share it and they don't want to share
it so they'd rather just not do it on
the on the internet not too long ago
my positive the idea that Warner
Brothers should do a Constantine Lucifer
crossover like you know even [ __ ]
like to our movie miniseries 10 episodes
whatever and I had a kind of good
authority that like Warner Brothers
isn't interested in that like Tom Ellis
wants to do it like Matt Ryan seems like
he wants to do it there's a bunch of
writers who wants to write it like yeah
I don't want to make that money never
quite understood there's big sort of
movie yeah it just doesn't make a lot of
sense it's just sitting there for you
guys just they have so much that's just
sitting there though mm-hm so the
library upset for acceptance that I own
the IP two right they'll just like sit
on it forever and and not do anything
but they won't let it go because god
forbid someone else do it so I've said
this before a few times and it's not
like I even watch the show because again
I didn't have a TV but for some reason
I've got in my head that Katie and I
should do Cagney and Lacey fun I think
we should - we've been talking about it
forever
you should totally [ __ ] do it it'd be
so much fun I want to see and I and I
actually researched speaking of Warner
Brothers because I think that it was
actually them who had the rights to it I
wanted I seriously my favorite show
growing up as a kid was Night Court and
I write and I so badly wanted to do like
a female version of Night Court I just I
loved the idea of you know this judge
who's you know dressed as a clown
underneath learn magic though yeah who
who would you cast as your Markie Post
the like himbo lawyer love interest many
beautiful boys
[Laughter]
I know it's just like like quick kid in
a candy store and my eyes went so bad
was like yes me swiping right yes
[Laughter]
Oh [ __ ] digression because I can do
it too but you guys been listening to
the Dolly Parton's America no big fan of
doll you know it is it's a podcast
series that radio lab is doing it's a
nine part thing just sort of
investigating the Dolly Parton of it all
and the fact that that a she's
thoroughly unrecognized and unheralded
as a songwriter yes and the work that
she did especially when she was younger
between like 21 to like 30 is on the
same parallel as like Lennon and
McCartney and Bob Dylan and just this
vast library of as she calls them sad
ass girl songs and like their sad
[ __ ] songs like they'd and they dive
into it and what dolly means in America
what she meant 30 years ago what she
needs today the the willingness she has
to puncture her own image and she knows
exactly what she looks like and she
knows exactly where the jokes are coming
it's very it's very 8 mile that way but
it's and also the ability of Dolly
present-day dolly to unify people in a
way that few entertainers can do like
you go to a dolly concert and it is the
United Colors of Benetton like
everybody's there because she's singing
songs about poverty and lack of
opportunity and and sort of celebrating
you know your own Moxie and everybody
can kind of wire into that I have
nothing else to say besides you should
listen to this [ __ ] podcast because
it's got a lot of Dolly in it which is
nice but a lot of perspective on dolly
especially from the host is a guy named
Jed a boom rod who's Lebanese like his
parents were born in Lebanon
his dad was a huge Dolly Parton fan in
Lebanon Oh interesting
and because I made the interview this
like this Nigerian woman who sings Dolly
Parton cover songs because they all grew
up poor they all had these little shacks
in the middle of the mountains somewhere
and she's singing about living with like
the moss on the trees and mud shotgun
Shack and my quarter million colors in
my Texas Tennessee mountain home and
like everybody can kind of understand
what that means no matter where you're
from
so you should listen even if you're not
a dolly fan but dolly is a national
treasure dolly it's amazing she was
kinda great I saw her in concert like
two years ago amazing she's amazing this
woman I thought I was like there are
moments in life when I become very tough
very I'm not I'm not like overtly like
I'll punch you in the face like that's
not who I am
unless you [ __ ] with my family and then
but we were there with my mom and my mom
doesn't get out much she doesn't like
crowds and she was so excited to see
dolly at the Hollywood Bowl and you can
eat food at the Hollywood Bowl my mom
had chips and she was so excited and she
had her wine because she adds ice to
wine so she had her wine and she was
drinking her wine and eating chips
sitting down we were in like a boxy
watching dolly and she was so happy and
so excited and so just like it was like
the best moment of my life to see my mom
that engaged and that excited and this
woman reached literally reached over and
grabbed my mom's chips and went can you
not oh damn [ __ ] you cannot
[Applause]
and she wasn't even being loud like I
mean she was right next to me and it
wasn't annoying me so like calm down
like this is everyone's eating half the
people are drunk like calmed I was so
upset Dolly was amazing that fur coat
off that woman stopped that cold [ __ ] in
California PETA
I have no dolly stories beyond watching
9:00 to 5:00 and feeling things what's
this picture about that feminism I'm on
board
this is great you tell poison that guys
called me which happens unlike birds
help them do it
[Laughter]
no that's Daniel Craig right I just saw
something the other day about him like
it was a blurb that hit the one of the
scenes that I was like what is this I've
never even heard about it sure it's you
can tell no no go for it I was talking I
sworn I think he's so handsome
the Daniel Craig who he is doing the
best foghorn leghorn
I've ever heard a brick dude he is
having the most crazy-ass fun like it's
a donut with a donut hole in the donut
Oh what and he's like he gained a little
bit of like James Bond weight so he's
like stretching this little tweed suit a
bit just I guess he's he's totally [ __ ]
on that collar but it's it's it's a
[ __ ] murder mystery it's a murder
mystery the way they used to make murder
mysteries I heard it was up for cop
musical they sing Golden Globes no
musical comedy
in Category because international people
are dumb
what kind of category is that musical or
comedy who the same at all the one
musical of the year gets really lucky
come on guys you say well you said
you're gonna see it tomorrow I'm gonna
totally go see cats do you have to and
you have to go see it because they
pulled all the screeners they need the
money it's actually double if anybody
wants to go probably gonna swing it
around like one o'clock maybe an arc
light I'm not sure which one I have to
see this [ __ ] movie it's in the
bathroom
good tiny is there like here's your iPad
go sit in the parking lot nobody wants
it so you can have it cats I'm sure was
jockeying for Best Musical we didn't
even get best song I know that you know
what though you look at that cast and it
is just a tragedy you just it's like
amazing actor after amazing actor after
so talented after god I love that person
what were you thinking I mean it's more
like alimony palimony child support
college trying to be taken seriously
yeah like trying to be an actor pop star
sure maybe get a Grammy I don't know
loves cats okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
remember when Sean Sean Sean Sean young
like David Letterman right that would
have been you could you imagine if you
committed that hard in the movie was
that bad you got in it found out where
the casting call was like Here I am
everybody I already I already got my fix
playing a cat did it you probably never
saw because I'm super hard to see I
haven't even seen it on Sony's powers it
was a graphic novel powers mm-hmm so
Sony PlayStation did it where the
network once yes they did and yeah and
it was on it was on it called powers and
I played agent Lang FBI agent Lang whose
secret power is turning into a cat
didn't we both play black cat though oh
yeah we boosted but I got to play a live
version I got I got to turn into a cat
me no need to brag I'm you know they
didn't do they didn't do like the yeah
we both played pack black cat on it
spider-man mm-hmm video games but I
turned into a cat when I got aroused
[Applause]
ironically you do bite people I do oh if
I have a few drinks you've had a few
dreaming or a cat and you know what now
I'm playing Dracula this perfect cast
offense
perfect casting love it's like yeah it's
it's a form of love people that I love
get bit yeah and if you haven't been bit
you just are left out you feel a little
sad until it happens and then you're
like oh my god that hurts so bad
tomorrow night we're doing the bounce
argh lactic acid
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Oh knives out everyday I feel like
usually my job is to keep Kevin on track
when he is like so stoned he forgets
what he's talking about and I did we get
here oh right accents not but yeah so
knives out you should totally watch the
knives out it's crazy fun I loved it
it's so it's it's just well wrought it's
like a Swiss watch right like every
little line it counts every scene
matters it all escalates it adds up to
something it finds a way to also Trojan
horse a little bit of commentary in
there about Ana de Armas who plays the
lead is fantastic but she's amazing
nobody seems to know what country she's
from really funny char Peruvian made
Ecuadorian maid or whatever it's it's
kind of great but ryan johnson has
decided he maybe wants to make a sequel
to myself that would be amazing
right I'm hoping that he's making like a
cutlery themed series of murder mystery
things spoons forward a spoonful of
arsenic
right that could be hand just forked
this is fun name fork fork you I had a
ladle pun that I can't remember
great what about barbecue tongs right
there yeah more you can do this all day
right behind the bar productions
yeah we did it pay us our money what's
it about
you do the hard work you do the work
come on we've given you the inspiration
right yes sounds equal I just wanted to
make puns I loved it because I loved the
movie I thought it was so intelligent
and it reminded me of like playing clue
when I was a kid all about it I hate it
I never read the instruction so I was
like how do you play in shame we had it
look am I actually killing somebody just
roll the dice and yeah I would I don't
have that mind so every time I would
play I would just be like [ __ ] it I
don't know the pipe in the observatory
with the colonel with the mustard and I
wouldn't never get it right like this
game at that fire I want to play sorry
right know who wins Connect four
it's much easier boom although I am mean
game of Catan yeah
I don't know these games oh my god you
will get so addicted what we do on the
farm if you didn't play like Connect
four we played uno and we played and we
played with them what's that when I
brought down to Cabo the one where you
yell it's a commodities game oh yeah but
it's it's very it's very similar to
Catan in a sense but it's more like
jackass it's more like we scream and
[ __ ] yeah you have commodities it's
about the stock market and ours on the
farm was an old one was my grandmother's
it was about wheat and barley and oats
and you have to get the st. you have to
get nine in each one and then you could
quarter the market if there's a lot of
yelling there's a lot it's like two two
two two two two three three three you
change exchange cars and then there's a
bear in a bowl the Bears bad good unless
your reason behind the capitalists now
the new one is gold and silver and oil
and okay
can I can I say yeah I'll admit
something in public I do not understand
I understand the thing about a stock
market i watch trading places every
Christmas because it's one of my
favorite Christmas movies
I still have no idea what happens at the
end of that movie because I don't like
okay so we got the frozen concentrated
orange juice futures and we know and so
we're buying low and selling high but
then we're calling and people like I
just don't what the [ __ ] is happening
and every year like Fortune magazine
will I put out some explainer from
morons like me of here's what's
happening you dummkopf this is how the
stock market works and I'm like not
helping I'm not gonna give a [ __ ]
because I don't care and then the next
year comes like I just like orange juice
this is cool Eddie Murphy is gonna win
right yes thank you very much were you
going to you can explain to me how it
works all right can we get this man a
microphone and he can explain to me
exactly how the [ __ ] you know Billy Ray
Valentine gets a yacht by the end of
that movie okay so hi guys hey what's
your name my name is Aviv Ivy yeah thank
you so much for eliminating me on my
decades-old quest to understand Trading
Places did you know that mr. Rogers his
car was stolen
and when he well then when the thieves
discovered it was Fred Rogers as par
they returned it okay so in Trading
Places
so in Trading Places
they're selling future and saying they
can set sell prices at buy prices so
they're they're driving up the price
really really high at first and then
they're setting their sell prices so
there's everybody that they promised to
sell at let's say ten dollars right and
then when the real orange juice report
comes out and the they were all lying or
whatever and the price drops then
they're doing their buy prices so
they're buying the stock low and selling
it high at the same time which is how
they get all that money if you don't get
it it's fine manipulating the market did
you fall
did cuz you're way smarter than I am I
still trust me I'm not I mean like that
was like explaining to a four-year-old
and I'm still [ __ ] lost
but I appreciate they got in trouble for
it that they did not get in trouble for
and it wasn't illegal at the time that's
right incredibly illegal getting getting
insider information from government
sources was not illegal at the time and
wasn't illegal until like the Obama
administration yeah I mean she just came
a couple years too late now she's so
relatable now though dog yeah
but they they made a lot of names in
prison they made a law making it illegal
in like 2011 and they call it the Eddie
Murphy role do you think it's because
like President Obama watch Trading
Places one Christmas it was like that
feels a little we shouldn't do that
somebody get me somebody on the phone
from regulation we are on but I'll stop
to this right now
this feels wrong yet if you're rich you
can still invest in
racehorses tonight your tax money as a
shelter so you can still do that rules
don't apply if you're rich no course not
okay we have one last news story and
they're going to get to the qat
which should be fun because we have [ __ ]
to give away and that was a rhyme sweet
writing I mean it
Thank You nerds Christian Bale is gonna
be in a [ __ ] Marvel movie damn it I'm
sorry kidding
oh it's don't work that's okay he died
[Laughter]
in Thor but he's gonna be in the one
with Natalie right he's gonna be the one
that Lee yes Kristen Bell's gonna be in
Thor for love and thunder yeah his his
role is still being put under wraps but
I find it so delightful that like
Christian Bale's like you know what [ __ ]
it I was Batman once why can't I be like
a third banana in the fourth or movie
why not Cate Blanchett did it she looked
real good baby okay Blanchett like she
did not leave a bit of scenery unchewed
know and I was impressed by it I love
watching her work just makes me excited
i I've never seen anybody look like
they're having more fun and she's so
pretty she's she looked like a little
butterfly if the golden clothes gonna
see you real shitty dresses they're her
dress was really shitty too often it was
a color of a baby blanket but that yeah
it was like it looks like she was about
to take off
cuz she said Larry she's the fairy is
she so perfect yeah the dresses were
really bad they were bad there was a
cover whoa mmm if I ever get there I
will be I won't get much better than
that if I never at the Golden Globes
look we're gonna wear as whoo that lamin
dress JLo's cause it'll be like the one
time I'm there and I might [ __ ] it
notice me
I do not care if I lose for I have
already won Rock Falls you guys we're
here all night okay so we're gonna move
on to the Q&A and if you guys are in the
mood to sign some stuff yeah fine people
have left good things you know what I
have in my purse
oh you brought a thing when I went what
I just realized I had it when I saw the
little Funko pops I have a little
Starbuck Lego oh I did in my office when
I was going through my shop when I was
trying to find things for my shop yeah
so we can add that to the who wants a
little thing I had a bunch of sixes and
I'm like well that's not me I gotta give
that Katy okay so we are giving away
thanks to our good friends Brett deacon
at the 40x we got a bunch of [ __ ] 40
X [ __ ] to give away
have you guys ever been to a 40 X
theater we talked about last time it
wasn't here so we're doing it for the
cheap seats it is like if you were a
person who hates going outside but once
like pretend that you like going outside
go see a 40 X movie because like you're
sitting in this seat oh that's one like
spit on you and stuff yes but it's it is
totally not a dude just standing over
you see I really like the seat right
Stevie seat moves like in the in I saw
rogue one uniform that would be a good
Renda same and like it like when the
crawl starts it slowly moves back and
when there's wind over the wind is
blowing that's why we said if you'd seen
like a dogs journey you would have been
like well this sucks
oh I'm not even like the fun sucks no
the dream is alive so yes we have we got
five sets of tickets today house and we
got one more thing I picked this up at
Long Beach Comic Con I saw it and I said
this would be a great giveaway it is the
season 3 press kit for Battlestar
Galactica the good folks at Golden Apple
comics were like you should use this as
giveaway and I said I will but it's
gorgeous
oh yeah that one I remember that one
yeah this was there like the we got a
[ __ ] Peabody we would spend some
money [ __ ] and so they spent all this
money is here the Pima hunt he's went
downhill
us in South Park people were like what
[Applause]
right James those are all really pretty
pictures never nominated for a Golden
Globe [ __ ]
so yes I figure like the best question
of the night we'll get this thing signed
by our my co-hosts oh there I did watch
it yeah so I said yeah while they ask
their questions and we ponder our
answers you guys can sign what you need
to sign and so yeah let's do some
questions who do we got first
Jacy yes he is hello check check
okay so this guy alright that was
suspenseful moment but we've got David
lavera David good the the rules are you
have to ask a question that all three of
us can answer oh that was empty
oh well listen I can always jump in and
be like listen it was so hard
episode three twelve actually no I do
have a arrow too so one I guess it would
be for the three of you guys what show
have you auditioned for and did not get
the part and when it aired you were
happy that you did not get it I can't
answer this question what show did you
audition for and didn't get the part but
when an aired you were glad you did it
[Music]
didn't audition for it though I'll start
it was a show that I went up to staphon
it was gonna be my very first TV show
this must have been 2010 and there was a
show on NBC I'm not sure if you guys
remember this but it was about a do to
work cape and it was called the Cape and
the Cape was the part of the Dukes
costume that had like superpowers and
[ __ ] so he was just kind of stand there
in his cape would do [ __ ] like the
boringest version of Doctor Strange
you know cuz that he couldn't do one of
magic and just as Kate it outlasted all
of like eleven episodes before I got
canceled but I wanted that job so
[ __ ] bad like I went nightly prep for
it I read the pilot script and it was
garbage but whatever and I went in there
and and didn't get the job and then I
saw the show and I had friends were like
they really could have used you on the
Cape and I said no
there's nothing that I could have done
to fix the Cape so that is my story if
the bullet dodged mines necessarily like
a bullet dodged it's more like oh you
didn't get that but then you got this
right after hmm um I really wanted the
role in once upon a time as Emma Swan
and I went in like six times for it I
auditioned so many times I wanted it so
bad didn't get it and then got longmeyer
like a week later hmm
you know I I was drawing a blank but I
auditioned a couple times for the evil
one yeah for a lot of Priya's role yeah
and didn't get it and then yeah I got
something else afterwards so some
justice been meant to be did you
remember Ron Moore's pilot that y'all
did 17th precinct that one I wanted that
so bad and I auditioned and went in for
it and they didn't hire me and I and
then he hired like so many people from
Battlestar and I was like yeah you know
what I bet sorry it was it was a pilot
that was it was a police procedural
where magic was the norm instead of
science and it was really really
interesting script yeah Stockard
Channing the one that I did and James I
did I'm sorry no it was it was one they
didn't actually want to see me for a
long time and then they finally saw me
and I got the role like right away and I
but you know it was it was one of those
lucky situations where Eamon Walker was
already cast as aleni
he's amazing I love him so much and I
had worked with him he had done a lawyer
show and I guessed it on this a lawyer
show there was a CBS I can't remember
what it was called and he was so nice to
me the rest of the cast were not it was
just one of those where they didn't
really talk to each other and
and he was so nice to me he actually did
something he was a Battlestar fan so he
actually owned it so when I went in to
read for I was really nervous because
ROM was in the room and like it's
actually hard to audition for somebody
you know really well from something else
because it's it's just weird and but
because Amon was there and I was reading
with him instead of reading with the
casting director it just felt
comfortable and I'd worked with him and
and he's such a lovely man a man Walker
Chicago Fire the captain I know him as
Adebisi from Oz oh yes and it's such a
good show so [ __ ] brutal and I
remember seeing JK Simmons like in a
restaurant and like skirting the long
way to the restroom because I'm like
that dude just rapes people all the time
that's like his big Vern Schillinger is
a crazy Nazi rapist dude with Mariska
Hargitay Christopher Chris Mary Chris
Meloni I saw in Oz and I literally was
like oh [ __ ] you ain't in an Ziegfeld
show anymore well dude does that answer
your question do we did we hit the sweet
spots then you win some ticket thank you
are we going now Jason all right we got
Rob Sanchez to the girls and also for
you why are you looking back to BSG why
do you think that series has held up so
well and it's a fan as well well thing
we're doing a podcast of it now we're
doing a rewatch of it yeah no we're
we're intimately prepared to solve this
particular question we're doing one
tomorrow night I think it's that it's it
is about things that are true and like
real truth is sort of temporally fluid
right like it's to show that it's about
after it's about genocide it's about
torture it's about salvation it's about
faith and it's about all of these things
that do not feel like they need to be
pegged in a particular time in a
particular place and it talks about them
in such a way that it allows those
themes to be somewhat eternal so when
you go back and watch a show like
Battlestar and I feel the same way and I
mentioned it when we had Ron Moore on
the show The West Wing also feels that
way and that they're talking about gun
control they're talking about drug
violence they're talking about
hurricanes and natural disasters and
they're talking about all of these
things that are still things we talk
about as a society as people between us
interpersonally and Battlestar does a
lot of that stuff and it's about at its
core it's about the relationship between
these people and we feel those people
and we feel their wants and their needs
and we feel their their their victories
and their defeats and so that's that's
what a show gets to be somewhat immortal
is when the characters are strong enough
and the themes are relevant enough and
anytime you'd watch it maybe can't add
to that you know and watching it now
it's actually almost more poignant now
or as poignant like it's it's it's
really it's been stunning for me to do a
rewatch of it and just be kind of taken
in because there's enough time that has
passed that I can actually watch it kind
of as a viewer a little bit I mean
you're still reminded of things on the
day of being there or something but it's
just it's stunning to watch some of the
like some of the your stuff and like
it's it's just it hits a core but yet at
the same time it's set in space where
you can still kind of remove yourself
from your day to day and enjoy it as
entertainment but yet it's hitting you
in a place where you're really affected
by it
right I have to answer this so you don't
get your price well you could say like
what she said yeah pretty much the same
thing you know I mean I think because we
were a science-fiction show we were very
much dismissed as not real so we could
do whatever we wanted and Ron Moore and
the writers used that opportunity to to
comment on everything that was going on
in the world at the time
so we were very much the only show that
was doing it at the time because
everybody else was not allowed to touch
it
and so I think that it is a very
authentic look at at that time in our
our in history but also the entire point
of Battlestar is that you know well not
the entire point but you know they say
it so much is that this this too shall
happen again like its its history
continues to repeat itself because human
means don't change we continue to make
the exact same mistakes over and over
and over again so how are they will
happen again right that thing I never
had to say it but the you know what I
mean humans don't evolve we don't change
we get smarter and technology gets
better but at our core we're still as
flawed as we've always been so we'll
always continue to make the same
mistakes and that's the sad truth of it
yeah one of the things that Trish and I
are always kind of struck by is how
especially watching it now what it must
be like to have like capable leadership
made of people who are like smart and
careful and moral and who think deeply
about issues and causes and effects and
there's a lot of times like man you know
I [ __ ] wish they like Laura Rossum
with one for actual president because I
would much prefer the Rosslyn presidency
for all of its problems
really why
although she did in the end of last year
she did almost just her she did try and
steal the election she totally did but I
get why she so yeah just it's it's it is
always it continually reinforces its own
level of quality
I simply continue to exist at a time
where we are as flawed as we've always
been and there's always a like I pray
that we find ourselves in the hands of
leaders who think is deeply about issues
as the ones on that show did thank you
thank you come get ticket all right
Jonathan Charles mr. Charles yeah mark
ladies how are you good how you doing
fantastic good so my question is in
regards to Joker but not so much what
you feel about the movie itself so this
is a movie that made over a billion
dollars biggest r-rated grossing movie
of all time has now got 11 Oscar
nominations what do you think or what do
you hope the Hollywood will take away
from this movie and as we all know
Hollywood tends to take the wrong
message away from successful movies so
what do you hope they'll take away from
it and what do you think they will
actually take away from it yeah I mean I
I think they will take the same thing
they always take from this sort of thing
which is hey we should we should plumb
our IP and just do more of this because
I do think that the Joker doesn't make a
billion dollars if it's called Arthur
and there's no references at all to the
DC Universe if it's just like a
disaffected dude who like
kind of goes mad and does awful things
if it's not a Batman movie it doesn't
make a billion dollars so I think that
it gives them cover to do interesting
things because they kind of know that
they can get it back and so I wish they
would just take more chances on things
like maybe that Arthur movie would have
been more interesting if it didn't have
to find ways to bend over and make
itself a Batman movie at the same time
the thing I wish they would take from it
is come on Bart I wish they would take a
closer look at the ways they portrayed
mental illness on screen I think that
that for some of the ways that the movie
is smart about it it's also very lazy
about it it's he's got a very specific
ailment and then a general I'm crazy
ailment and and I think that specificity
is what makes movies work it's what
makes us respond to them and the more
research you do and that the more
accurate a picture you can portray of
that actually the better drama you get
to squeeze out of it and so just the
they like what's his thing well he
laughs a lot and he's also kind of crazy
and also kind of a sociopath and also
kind of a felt a lot like the the Saffir
platter of mental illness and a little
bit more responsibility in that angle
would be nice yeah I don't know I I saw
it I know you had I wasn't here didn't
see it but I know you you talked about
it in one of these and you had specific
thoughts on it I I watched it and I was
disturbed for a couple of days after I
was in like this weird and I couldn't
quite put my finger on it and maybe that
maybe you just articulated it sort of
what it was was yeah I have a sister
with some mental illness and and
I was watching it not to that extreme in
terms of violence and stuff but it was
so gratuitous in many ways but it was
also like I couldn't quite put my finger
on what what was upsetting me for days
but I was in a fog for a couple of days
and to me at the time I was like that
just means it was a really good movie if
it if it's got me sitting there thinking
for a couple of days but it was so
disturbing and I was watching it with
and he Lucifer fan zero was watching
with DB Woodside friend of mine and we
were both just like we sat there we were
gonna go to dinner afterwards and then
he had to go pick up a sister up at the
airport and we kind of looked at each
other at the end of the movie and went
yeah I don't think dinner would have
been a good idea like yeah and I texted
to the next day I'm like are you still
like in a funk and he said yes and I
couldn't quite put my finger on it but
maybe that's it but there was one this
is an answer your question at all but
there was one point in it talking about
coming back to the beginning of when I
was saying sometimes you need to give an
audience a little bit of breathing room
I had a moment in that movie that I got
I got the nervous giggles because it was
so intense for so long that it was when
his mom had just had the stroke and he
was sitting out there and the detective
come up to him and he's starting to feel
stressed because obviously he had done
the get killed the people and he goes to
walk in the exit of the glass door he
hits himself really hard on the I
couldn't stop laughs I was crying
laughing and it was not a funny moment
it was just it was him as a little funny
but it was gonna be you also laughed
when you dropped a motorcycle on me so
like and when shrine' fell off a cliff
yeah but it's your go-to when you're
uncomfortable never has been in my life
until recently I guess something
happening with the age I'm in where I'm
starting to get nervous giggles when
it's something that really affects me
and I got the nervous giggles in this
and because I was giggling DB was
looking at me like I'm a boil and
frankly I don't know why the very end
I'm gonna
because you giggling is weird and I
built a oh and we're just like sitting
there trying not to laugh but it wasn't
funny it was like this disturbing and I
almost wanted to cry at the same time so
it's I'm not answering a question but I
just think that they'll probably take
from it that let's just show more grits
like the violent side of it instead of
the what's actually causing some of the
the problem I think you guys both said
everything pretty eloquently I mean you
know I think what Hollywood is gonna
take from this is that you know our
rated movies that have a vehicle behind
them are you know let's just make more
r-rated movies so I think they'll do
that and continue to like you said
branch off with the IPS that they have
and instead of give new voices an
opportunity to create content you know I
think that we have an overabundance of
hundred million dollar movies and and
you know we've got a really great five
million dollar indie sort of you know
existence right now but we've really
lost the twenty million dollar movie
which we think that there is an
opportunity for those and I wish that
those would come back but I so I don't
know I don't know what I wish that they
you know you touched on the the violence
and you touched on some stuff so I don't
really know what I wish that died I
don't know it's such an interesting
question I said they're gonna make a
sequel to her right yeah I mean it was
like he's like glorified now for yeah I
mean Todd Phillips claimed that he
doesn't quite have an idea for it but
maybe and Joaquin I think is attracted
by the idea of making a sequel but also
repulsed a little bit by having the
process of having to make a movie like
the physical transformation the
emotional just living in that zone for a
while it's funny I had to your point I
introduced a screening at the Alamo
Drafthouse of pitch-black
governments ago and and the thing that
struck me was that was a twenty two
million dollar movie that's not based on
anything that there's no movie stars
that is just David to II had an idea and
movie studio and they gave him twenty
two million dollars to make that movie
and it's great and it's lean and it's
smart and it's very effective and it's
wonderfully diverse and because you
couldn't have done that movie for six
but you didn't need a hundred you didn't
need a hundred like I just needed this
much yeah and that was a world in which
you could get twenty two million dollars
to make a grown-up kind of mature
science fiction thriller without needing
a comic book or a book or a sequel or
whatever and I miss those days
yeah me too those are some swings I
agree completely that's what I wish that
they would take from it - did we get
close yeah that's great thank you
awesome Thank You Man we've got Cowell
Michael hey uh so um oh great something
to remind me I've had a few drinks so if
you mark the Nardin had hi had a chance
to do a Caprica esque remake so set in
that era how would you do it and how
would you involve these two ladies in it
because I believe that I believe that
Caprica had a lot of hope and I'm in
love with the last episode and that's
all I'm gonna say about that okay
so I will sort of answer your question
in that I had been approached that
talked about the podcast before back at
Mike
Lawson you do it talked about the fact
that that
I had put together I pitched a
Battlestar reboot because I was
approached by some executives who like
we have the rights we're gonna do it
what's your take on it
and and the first thing that I said was
I have to talk to Ron like I need Ron's
blessing even before I think about it
and so I ran into him and backstage at
New York Comic Con I'm like listen this
is gonna be super [ __ ] weird I know
but they asked me if I want to do this I
don't know if I should do it I wanted to
talk to you about it I may never get the
job I don't know but I don't even want
to go down this road unless I know that
you're cool with it
he said yeah totally i rebooted this
from somebody else you should be able to
reboot this from me just don't touch the
stuff that I made up like leave me my
Roslin's leave me my you know athena's
leave me my like everything that was
unique to this show leave leave alone
but you can have your guys Baltar you
can have your Apollo you can have your
you know Adama all of that stuff that
came from the 70 show you can go for it
and so but my take was I I didn't want
to see any humanoid robots I was like I
feel like that's the grand innovation of
Ron's series was based somewhat out of
budget is I know we can't afford to do
Centurions all day long what if they
look like humans and then what does that
story-wise give you but as I don't want
that I wanted to do a show about that we
are surrounded by technology that we
have we have surrendered so much of
ourselves to the technology around us I
don't know how to get anywhere anymore I
used to remember every phone number of
everybody I knew I can't anymore
we have seated so much of our own agency
in the world
through the technology around us and
then what if that technology goes bad
you know and we start to see bits of it
we're lied there's some Alexa in a house
that's listening to [ __ ] that it
shouldn't be listening to and giving
information to places it shouldn't be
giving it to but there's gonna be
self-driving cars soon there's gonna be
robots that do surgery soon there's
gonna be drones delivering everything as
skies and it clogged with robots there's
gonna be gonna be gonna be and what
happens with that all turn
and what if the world that's around us
rebels against us that's the show that I
had wanted to do and I think there's
there was a there was a character she
was a police captain named Jane Adama
who I think Trisha would have been very
nice for I think she was the protagonist
of the show and she had two kids what
was her name [ __ ] wasn't Jane was
something else whether she had two kids
Apollo and Athena one of which went into
the police the other which became a
doctor and and I think that that you'd
be awesome for the doctor you're welcome
can I can i chime in real quick it's
your mom in the Sun so you know there's
this mystery in regards to Starbuck in
the last season and I I feel that there
is such an opportunity there for time
travel and also with six being a Cylon
and being immortal I think that's a
grand opportunity you should write it
but no man that's an awesome question I
think yeah do we think awesome man thank
you did we answer it for you do you all
right we got one more question then we
choose the recipient of the grand
awesome previously free public relations
gift
[Laughter]
Richard Soriano
thank you hey Richard hi how are you
good
that's he just say last year I finished
watch I was in the hospital last year
and I finished watch Battlestar
Galactica just slopped the show love you
guys so thank you my question is you
know as fans of science fiction and
writers and actors of science fiction
what what scientific advances of today
that excites you the most and what
terrifies you
I just went hard on terrifies before I
kind of well this sort of excites me and
terrifies me at the same time I kind of
like the idea of like another layer of
traffic in LA
like hover hover so it kind of excites
me but it also terrifies me because I
don't think there's that many good
drivers they should only allow the good
drivers job you should have to pass a
real hard test and they could never have
had a ticket for like 25 years or
something crazy ticket part but but yeah
yeah yes when I so a year ago I bought a
Mustang right like I was it was my
[ __ ] midlife crisis car like I'd
always wanted one like I got a good ass
job I'm buying a [ __ ] car
and so I Drive a 5.0 I Drive up the
Trish's house and she's like hey you got
a Mustang I'm like yeah
is it a 5.0 and I and I said no it's a
2.4 EcoBoost and you went
but it's awesome giddyup it just again
sure does hey so that's why I'm not
speeding tickets I'm predictable the big
boy car convertible oh ok where are you
gonna drive it in Los Angeles that fast
that's what I said thank you there's no
need for it so yeah okay so you had so
you had the the bi-level traffic you
want the Fifth Element version of Los
Angeles what you think I'm to fold on
things that I think are absolutely
amazing but they both also terrify me
the the advancements in medical
technology are absolutely phenomenal
it's you know we are living longer than
ever before I we've got more cures for
incurable diseases we we have abilities
to you know grow organs and save people
with the terrible diseases but at this
and and on the same side of that the
advancements in technology for
communication have absolutely
revolutionized the way that we talk to
each other and the way they would
communicate it's so easy now to to Skype
your family where sometimes you didn't
see them for like five years and now you
pick up Skype and you feel like you see
them every day the downside of that is
you don't see your family anymore and
you feel like you see them every day so
you're not really connecting anymore or
we're texting we're having these
communication and conversations that
don't really exist and then also you
know I think that if people would just
take care of themselves better we
wouldn't need all those advancements in
medical health to a certain extent so I
think that I think that I don't know
both of those are amazing and they also
both terrify me tremendously because
we're gonna start growing people soon
yeah yeah for sure
I remember reading the article must have
been like seven or eight years ago that
there was some scientists at MIT or at
some other place with
keep big brains who had like
theoretically cracked faster-than-light
travel like he didn't have the machinery
to make it yet it was all theoretical
it's like [ __ ] Einstein [ __ ] where's
like I don't I believe this to be true
but I can't test it because you wouldn't
have the tech yet to build it but that
idea that somebody figured out here's
the formulas that we wouldn't need
here's the materials we might want which
don't exist yet to do that thing that
we've always wanted to do which is
travel the [ __ ] stars is so exciting
to me in as a kid to grow up on Star
Wars and Star Trek like that seems to be
where humanity is supposed to be granted
we will also [ __ ] this place up before
we get to do that and there will be lots
of reasons why we have to leave but and
I'm always [ __ ] frightened to death
every time I see some new video out of
like Boston Dynamics where they've
created some robotic I can open doors
now like look at these stairs
gallop-gallop-gallop I'm like [ __ ] you
like you guys you're the reason why
we're gonna get like Cyberdyne systems
like there's gonna be terminators
because of you have you never seen the
movies we know how this goes stop doing
this like I sign it a day where it was
like delicious we've got like ed-209
except they could do stairs and I'm like
why would you do that you saw the movie
the only reason maybe surprise because
he can't go downstairs and you go [ __ ]
stairs I got this clean your own damn
house seriously wiping your ass anymore
I can do stairs did you see they came
out with one I just saw yesterday or
today that that was actually made out of
organic material course it was
that's for sex toys sorry it's the first
living robots from frog stem cells oh
good also for sex toys every every major
took me I can't do stairs for the wrong
reasons like we built a camera you guys
what should we do take pictures of like
animals and flowers yeah
now how do we choose which video
formatted to make up the consumer leader
wide lens porn lira coin decided we
would do VHS a naught beta porn decided
we would do blu-ray and not HD DVD they
don't like the high-definition note do
they know VR like I want to go my scene
in then
[Applause]
40x for all of your home needs if they
don't if they don't make that their
commercial for the service now than
they've missed a golden opportunity done
50 shades of 40 yet here's your 3d
glasses enjoy the poncho this is our
robot she will be serving totally
different place how's that for scary-ass
technology it sounds exciting
fluids flying out to the speed of sound
[Applause]
speaking of news how excited are you for
the next matrix I mean I know we're not
on that right now
I am crazy excited because I I had been
a casual Yaya Abdullah teen fan and then
saw him and watch men I'm like that
[ __ ] is gonna be in a matrix
IOP as his pants on because I don't want
to feel bad about myself again did you
watch any of Watchmen so I have now
watched Watchmen yes we're on episode
like Swit six seven okay we're going how
many are there eight and nine alright
alright so we got like two left I'm sure
we'll watch it when I get home tonight
um and it's fantastic it's wonderful and
super smart yeah there's a scene and I
want to say it's episode eight I just go
straight to Episode eight yes oh damn
dr. Manhattan doesn't wear any pants
yeah well she takes out their frickin
cuz that is is like a it's like that's
foreshadowing very much so it's it's
eight shadowing like you pull it out and
everything
now anyway my and my boyfriend's a total
comic-book dork um no offense to anyone
that is because it's great but um he he
pulled it out of like this thing and I
was like what's that he was like Katie I
know and he wound it and paused it now
I'm like no there's three like we get to
see it I would have him in Night Court
his name is bull for all kinds of
reasons like pantsless Night Court
yeah why is everybody Winnie the Pooh in
this Night Court they got the shirts on
and then there's nothing on the bottom
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like I'm still standing here yeah
hold out there's gonna be some good
stuff at that movie who do we think
killed it the most with the question we
hear we get to choose we get to choose
should we do like audience yeah we
should sign on the front or on our
photos front your photos both everywhere
every page
also Social Security number blood time
all right so what were the questions JC
do you remember the questions we had we
had the Joker question okay round of
applause for Joker all right we had we
had that last question was about the
technology we're excited for technology
[Applause]
why why did Battlestar hold up so well a
mini pocket
oh he kept his what show have you
auditioned for and didn't get but we're
happy about it okay and then there was
that Battlestar read the question and
yes the yeah that pretty cool I feel
like it's why does Battlestar hold up so
well that's founded so for whom was that
question
[Applause]
he arrived in 3:30 this afternoon to sit
right here - so Wow hot damn what are
those things
I don't know what are these who brought
these things in the podcast every now
and then there no I thought let's give
the guys some cup coasters to put that
wine arm so at least at least the cats
can try to get laid
I'm here for the NAMM show that is Nana
hind this week and this is my company so
I thought that would be appropriate on
multiple levels so enjoy the code the
cup cows please thank you and so these
are vinyl coasters WWE gr NL from the
Netherlands yeah thank you
boys and girls I think that's the end of
an evening yeah did you guys have fun
today
I cannot thank you enough for coming out
I cannot thank JC and the good folks
here the scum and villainy Cantina for
continuing to host this insanity on a
semi-regular basis and I cannot thank my
co-hosts in that Tricia Helfer Katee
Sackhoff
we're coming out guys for coming out and
so that is an episode of black man
beyond next week
Kevin Smith is back in the hizzy so in
the 21st of January he will be here with
me and I don't know what the [ __ ] we're
going to talk about but we'll make it up
as we go but for now that is another
episode so come back next week same fad
time same fat channels SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith goodnight
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you